so you're a Chinese fentanyl dealer
business is booming and your
organization is making millions with all
this new money flowing in everything
should be great right wrong the really
annoying thing about having millions in
illegal cash is that it's really
difficult to spend because if you spend
too much cash eventually the government
is going to be asking where you got that
cash from
figuring out how to spend your illegal
money is a job in itself well that is
where money laundering comes in and
because the money is in China it's gonna
be a little bit more complicated than
the good old open a cash business type
of laundry you need to bring your money
out of China and into a foreign market
where you can enjoy The Spoils of your
riches in safety but that's going to be
a little difficult
you see China has this rule in place
that says people can't bring any more
than fifty thousand dollars out of the
country but fifty thousand dollars is
the amount you're making in an afternoon
with all the fentanyl sales so you need
a way to get a lot of money out of China
and into another country you need a
country that's close enough to China
that is easy to reach on a one-way
flight or boat ride at any time but you
also need a place that's far away enough
from Asia to be a little bit more
removed from the Chinese government's
influence that country also needs to
have a lot of imports and exports coming
through it year round so there's lots of
opportunities to smoke in drugs and
money and the country also has to be
super chill with very welcoming
immigration laws and the country needs
lots of casinos the country also needs a
healthy supply of drug users to be your
local customer base and it would be a
really big bonus if the place already
had a big Chinese Community or in other
words you need a place like Vancouver
Canada
this was the line of thinking that
Chinese organized crime followed as they
devised the plan to use Canada as the
washing grounds for one of the biggest
money laundering operations in the world
and Vancouver's casinos are at the heart
of the scheme a money laundering
bombshell money laundering has not just
uh taken money out of the Canadian
economy of BC's economy but has actively
hurt it was the largest money laundering
investigation in Canadian history this
is what's known as the Vancouver model
[Music]
you need a lot of skills to pull off
money laundering but you also need a lot
of skills to make legal money both pass
require skills but the legal route
doesn't end with you in prison so you
might as well take that one that's where
skillshare comes in skillshare is an
online learning community with thousands
of courses that allow people to explore
their passions look if you want to make
millions of dollars or become a business
leader one day you need to have the best
skills and skillshare can help you learn
those abilities on demand no matter what
field of work you're in or what topics
you're interested in you'll find it on
Scotia because there are so many unique
courses many of them can help you become
a better business person and make more
money like how to organize your workflow
to maximize productivity or this one on
30 principles for social success or this
one on Tick Tock marketing 101 if you
only have time to focus on one class I'd
recommend modern money habits five sets
to build the life he wants by Justin
Bridges a former Finance pro at Goldman
Sachs and current photographer the class
is all about using healthy money habits
to build the life you really want no
matter who you are there's a bunch of
experts teaching on skillshare right now
skillshare is always pointing out new
and interesting courses and there are
any distracting ads or interruptions
plus the entire course catalog is now
available with subtitles and Spanish
French Portuguese and German the first 1
000 my subscribers that go to
skillshare.com Jake will get a free one
month trial that's skillshare.com to
start learning today thanks to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
[Music]
now you may be wondering why Chinese
games would choose Canada out of all
places to launder their money What
attracted them to Vancouver well there's
actually a lot of logic behind the
choice first off location Vancouver
Canada is located on the western edge of
Canada right at the border with the US
it's basically the closest access point
to North America from China Chinese
immigrants have been moving to Vancouver
since the 1800s due to this Geographic
convenience there are plenty of direct
flights and even boats that go to
Vancouver from China because of how
close it is so it's an easy Western City
to get into once they're in Vancouver
they also have easy access to the US the
other great thing about Vancouver's
location is that it's a port city
meaning that there are always big boats
carrying lots of stuff coming into
Vancouver also known as a great tool for
smuggling in millions of dollars in cash
or containers full of drugs Canada also
has easygoing immigration laws compared
to many other countries this allows lots
of people in and Canada has plenty of
opportunities for them to make it
permanent this welcoming attitude caught
the attention of Chinese gangs because
not only could they easily get into the
country but they could also very easily
wash their money once they get there
enter Vancouver's casinos in addition to
relaxed immigration laws British
Columbia also had pretty hands-off rules
for the casinos while they had rules but
they weren't really enforced they were
so handoff that gangsters ended up
bringing back stuff with cash and they
will walk straight into their casinos
past security cameras and all and no one
would bat an eye but more on that later
there are also plenty of people who
wanted drugs in this area so the dealers
would never stop running out of
customers plus setting up shop in
Vancouver gave them Prime access to drug
customers in America too then there was
the final nail in the coffin the thing
that made Chinese crime syndicates move
their entire lives and businesses to
Vancouver and here's how it works
foreign
[Music]
China and your cash is trapped there
here's what you gotta do first you're
gonna need to make some transfers
remember that stupid fifty thousand
dollar limits yeah this is gonna solve
that problem you want to deposit your
millions of dollars in dirty money into
a bank account located in China owned by
criminals that also have money in
British Columbia they're gonna help you
facilitate this transfer to Canada
behind the Chinese government's backs
once it's in their accounts you book a
ticket and head to Vancouver once you
arrive the criminals will withdraw the
same amount of money you deposited in
China out of their own Canadian bank
accounts in Canadian dollars and hand it
to you for a fee of course in the end
these middlemen got money in their
Chinese accounts which Drew money from
their Canadian accounts while taking a
fee so they've made a profit and they're
happy you're probably going to want to
bring a bag because you're going to be
carrying a lot of physical cash and boom
you've successfully circumvented the
currency controls of China and move your
cash from China into Canada but you're
not done yet because you still have cash
that came from an illegal source so
that's where the casinos come into play
you go to a casino in Vancouver that's
owned by your gang or another gang and
you exchange the cash for chips now play
a few hands with those chips just a
couple of low risk bets to hold your
millions in the form of Casino chest for
a little bit then you finish up take
your gambling profits back to the
exchange counter and finally just
exchange your chest back into Canadian
dollars and boom you now have a receipt
showing that this money came from a
legitimate Source casino gambling
profits you started with a few chips and
won this money fair and square what
started out as dirty cash from the drug
trade has now turned into clean
laundered money with no clear link to
criminal organizations in China but most
importantly you are now free to deposit
that clean cash into a bank account and
if they ask where the money came from
you had the receipts from the casino to
prove it now that the money is in your
bank account you can spend your fortune
on whatever you want in the country you
can buy luxury cars expensive houses or
anything else that your heart desires
and the more stuff you buy and sell the
better because the more the money moves
around the further removed it is from
its illegal Origins and since Canada
doesn't have any laws about not being
able to move over fifty thousand dollars
out of the country now your money is
free to move wherever you want in the
world Canada was just a pit stop for it
obviously this is a little
oversimplified but it's the perfect
system for Chinese crime syndicates but
it's not so great for Canadian citizens
[Music]
allowing Chinese gangsters to freely use
Canada as their money laundering Heaven
has really negatively impacted the
country and its citizens these gangsters
weren't just bringing their illegal
money into Vancouver they were also
bringing a huge supply of drugs to sell
mainly Fentanyl and other opioids and as
they brought in these insanely addictive
drugs demand for them kept skyrocketing
as of June 2020 nearly 12 percent of the
Canadian population uses opioid pain
relievers in 2019 there were nearly 3
000 opioid related deaths in Canada and
it's an epidemic that Canada's neighbor
the United States knows all too well
Chinese gangsters didn't cause the
massive drug problem in Canada but they
definitely didn't help the situation by
bringing in even stronger drugs like
fentanyl the Vancouver model also
created some other unexpected
consequences Chinese organized crime was
cleaning so much money that they had to
spend it on something so these Ultra
Rich criminals pour their newly
laundered money into Vancouver real
estate and all around Canada in general
in 28 18 5.3 billion dollars worth of
real estate transactions in Canada were
funded by money laundering the result is
skyrocketing cost of living in British
Columbia the housing market in British
Columbia and Vancouver in particular has
been a hot one for a long time money
laundering is said to have increased
Canadian housing prices by 5 in 2018 but
the rise in housing costs are thought to
be way higher in Vancouver specifically
many local Canadians can't afford these
increasing housing costs so they're
forced out of the Cities they've lived
in for Generations while money
laundering drug dealers move in and get
comfortable even to this day about half
of the city's most expensive homes are
purchased using secretly structured
purchasing methods a tactic commonly
used by money launderers to invest in
real estates it was consequences like
these that finally made the government
take notice of what was happening and
they were about to uncover the biggest
money laundering operation in Canadian
history
foreign
[Music]
it took a while before the government
made a move on the Vancouver model
casinos generate a lot of tax revenue
for the British Colombian governments so
there was an incentive to not go after
the gangsters for years but in 2017
things would start changing CCTV footage
of criminals entering casinos carrying
suitcases or plastic bags full of cash
surfaces the footage showed gangsters
exchanging huge sums of money for chips
without a carrot in the world no one was
asking a single question in June of 2017
nine people are arrested in connection
with the Vancouver model it's believed
that the gang had learned over a hundred
million dollars through casinos in
British Columbia the discoveries Inspire
new anti-laundering laws in Canada the
laws required 24 7 surveillance at every
Casino in British Columbia and that
anyone entering with over ten thousand
dollars had to prove that the money came
from a legitimate Source the
investigations uncovered just how many
money laundering and Drug operations
there were in British Columbia such as
silver International Silver
International was an unregistered money
service that was the foundation for the
whole plots silver International was
laundering cash for drug dealers and
China Latin America and Canada the
directors of silver would arrange for
Chinese Nationals to deposit funds in
Chinese Banks and then pay them Canadian
cash in Canada which they were used to
gamble silver International was a bridge
that connected illegal money from China
to Canada in 2015 alone they had taken
over 220 million dollars in drug money
during The Reign the largest single
deposit was a 1.4 Million Dollar Cash
delivery in 2019 something called the
colon commission was announced after it
was estimated that over 7 billion
dollars was laundered in British
Columbia in 2018 alone so the Canadian
government finally cracked down on the
Vancouver model and money laundering
through British Columbia casinos has
gone down significantly since but that
doesn't mean it's gone for good casinos
were a big part of the massive money
laundering operation in Canada but the
key word there is Parts many money
launderers have turned to something
called Bank drafts as a way to keep
laundering through casinos and the
Vancouver model isn't confined to Canada
it's a technique that can be used in any
area that has casinos but how efficient
the model is for cleaning Dirty Money
all depends on how relaxed the laws and
regulations are in that area
I love Vancouver model I wanted to make
this video for a while so I hope you
guys enjoyed and if you're new here my
name is Jake Tran and we make
documentaries on money power and crime
for free for your viewing pleasure so
you might as well click that subscribe
button because you can always dislike
and unsubscribe whenever you want if you
want even more controversial
documentaries that are even longer every
single month click that join button
below there's a refund policy too so if
you don't like it for whatever reason I
will personally send you the money back
just email me you can follow me on
Instagram jaketrain.io watch out for
fake Instagram accounts I'm never going
to DM you asking for money or to invest
in crypto or whatever and that's pretty
much it thanks for watching stay
dangerous out there and I will see you
guys in the next one
foreign
[Music]